it's actually the very first fat con
what's that con is it just gonna be a
massive food haul that'd be cool is
lizzo performing this is the very first
of its kind Lane Bryant
come on what that's not mean I go to
fatcon all the time 2 am at Walmart I
read about it on like a site that was
like super hating on it looked like a
bunch of fat people getting together and
being happy that they're fat people
alone like I get the whole body
positivity it's like funny to hate on
this is actually good part of it's funny
to hate on what do you get it you can
enjoy this you don't even know what
happens here yet well yeah just go to
Comic-Con the intention behind it is
good like you said it's a safe space
it's more of a conference a lot of it's
supposed to boost your mental health as
a person with like an overweight body oh
[__] whack
what were you picturing how did we
survive till August